[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur public sénat édition spéciale de
présidentielle 360 voici les titres
un débat qui vire au pugilat entre
marine le pen emmanuel macron la
première confrontation télévisée entre
les deux finalistes de la présidentielle
a donné lieu à de véritables passe
d'armes
le candidat dans marche a dominé la
candidate fn sur les dossiers
économiques
on en parle dans un instant au lendemain
de ce débat la campagne a repris ses
droits
marine le pen a été visée par des jets
d'oeufs à son arrivée en bretagne
de son côté emmanuel macron est à albi
dans le tarn là aussi vous allez le voir
accueillis par des syndicalistes de la
cgt reportage à suivre
que retenir de cette campagne d'entre
deux tours il est dit à bien des égards
quels enjeux à trois jours du second
tour les électeurs de la france
insoumise vont-ils suivre les consignes
d'abstention ou de vote blanc analyse et
décryptage avec mes invités tout au long
de cette émission et je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez réagir en direct à cette
émission sur twitter le hashtag
présidentielle à 360 aux dernières
heures de campagne sur le terrain pour
les finalistes de cette présidentielle
ils seront tous les deux en meeting ce
soir emmanuel macron sur les terres de
jaurès à albi marine le pen dans la
somme à enova un village de 200
habitants choisi pour illustrer la
france d oublier ce matin la candidate
fn a été accueilli par des opposants en
bretagne qui lui ont jeté des oeufs et
l'accueil a également été musclé pour le
leader dans marche c'est ait fana malien
marine le pen évite de justesse un oeuf
à son arrivée à dol de bretagne sous les
sifflets de militants anti fascistes en
cet avant dernier jour de campagne
la tension monte d'un cran la candidate
frontiste a lancé les hostilités hier en
évoquant un prétendu comptes offshore de
son adversaire aux bahamas
les deux candidats se sont affrontés ce
matin par médias interposés je lui ai
posé la question est ce qu'on va où là
est-ce qu'on va découvrir des choses
peut-être trop tard qui concerne
emmanuel macron n'ai jamais eu de compte
dans quelques paradis fiscal que ce soit
et donc madame le pen lance cela est là
derrière des troupes sur internet qui
seraient tentés la s'organisait
prémédité d'évidence avec ses alliés que
j'ai dénoncée depuis le début de cette
campagne le candidat dans marche a
décidé de porter plainte contre x pour
propagation de fausses nouvelles
destinées à influencer le scrutin
en déplacement dans une verrerie à albi
emmanuel macron a pris le temps de
parler aux ouvriers un bain de foule et
un accueil plus chaleureux qu'à l'usiné
whirlpool damien la semaine dernière
l'état fait soixante milliards
d'économie moi je vais faire des
économies c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
renouveler certains postes de
fonctionnaires que je vais faire des
économies sur certains secteurs
parce qu'on en a besoin les deux
candidats feront leur dernier meeting ce
soir en plein air à albi pour emmanuel
macron marine le pen sera l aed main en
picardie et le soutien de barack obama
emmanuel macron dans une vidéo publiée
sur le compte twitter du candidat dans
marches l'ancien président américain
salue à la campagne menée on écoute je
sais que vous faites face à de nombreux
défis et je veux que tous mes amis en
france sache à quel point je veux votre
réussite
parce que cette élection est trop
importante je veux que vous sachiez que
je soutient emmanuel macron pour aller
de l'avant en marche
le débat aura donc duré 2h30 et les
échanges auront été particulièrement
vifs entre emmanuel macron et marine le
pen
il sent peu de place au fond retour sur
les temps forts avec héloïse grégoire un
débat sans merci ni courtoisie et bien
séance où tous les coups étaient permis
et à 21h tapantes les hostilités sont
lancées ces macro et le candidat de la
mondialisation sauvage de l'ubs et
risation de la précarité de la brutalité
sociale de la guerre de tous contre tous
deux du saccage économiques notamment de
nos grands groupes du dépeçage de la
france par les grands intérêts
économiques du communautarisme et tout
cela piloté par monsieur hollande
emmanuel macron tente de jouer la carte
de la sérénité mais réplique avec
véhémence vous êtes en train de lire une
fiche qui ne correspond pas au dossier
que vous avez cités c'est triste pour
vous parce que ça montre votre
impréparation à nos concitoyens des
échanges virulents et les attaques
personnelles
mais n'importe quoi mais ça devra le
fond se joue et ne jouais pas je joue
pas malheureux sur vous et vous cherchez
à jouer avec moi à l'élève au professeur
marc ce qui concerne ce n'est pas
particulièrement mon truc je me dis moi
très attendu sur sa sortie de l'euro
marine le pen est en difficulté on vous
proposait bien de sortir de l'eau non je
vais négocier pour que l'euro on s'en
libère et on le transforme en monnaie
commune c'est ce qui lève existe c'est
ce qu'il a il était avant qu'il devienne
la monnaie de la france avec de l'euro
et les choses soient très claires non ne
paiera pas de le renverser gayraud les
banques centrales perron avec de l'euro
si elles le souhaitent lusine whirpool
épisode emblématique de ce second tour a
été un des temps forts du débat étant
que vous faisiez vous votre numéro avec
les caméras
moi j'étais avec les représentants des
salariés parce que je les respecte et
vous savez quoi
ils ont bien compris que vous leur
proposez rien c'est la raison bien
compris vous l'approprier 12 ans le soir
même un cran mais oui parce qu'il est
l'air un peu plus de 16 millions de
téléspectateurs ont regardé le débat la
plus petite audience d'un duel d'entre
deux tours et dans notre multiplex on
retrouve tout de suite savait rien rouge
est con direct de la salle des
conférences du sénat à vos côtés le
sénateur centriste
il veut pozzo di borgo comment at il
vécu ce débat savait rien bonjour yves
pozzo di borgo
bonjour quel est votre sentiment
justement à l'iss au lendemain de ce
débat bernard acoyer tout à leur parler
d'un triste spectacle est ce que vous
êtes d'accord
écoutez c'est quand même un débat que
les français ont regardé j'ai quand même
été surpris choqués je veux dire que le
niveau de marine le pen notamment
lorsqu'elle parlait de l'euro s'était
pas c'était pas le niveau d'une
présidentielle j'avais l'impression
d'avoir une étudiante qui essaie
d'expliquer un exercice qu'elle a mal
compris moment et ça ça marche ça m'a
choqué pour l'europe ça m'a choqué si
vous voulez que que son explication sous
l'euro soit aussi confuse
intellectuellement et ça c'était pas
digne de la france
là vous ne disait que vous aviez
également relevé des erreurs de la part
d' emmanuel macron bon c'est vrai que
manuel macro est encore jeune il a
quelques mais c'est vrai que c'est au
niveau économique est quand même
beaucoup plus solide que marine le pen
ça m'a rassuré c'est d'abord nous le
groupe hurlus dirhams au niveau du
bureau politique
nous votons pour lui nous avons dès le
lendemain du premier tour d'appeler à
voter pour emmanuel macron parce que les
deux candidats c'est comme chaque fois
au premier tour on choisit de tourner
les mines et on pouvait pas donc
vote pour emmanuel macron est-ce que
vous pensez que ce débat a pu changer le
vote modifier le vote de certains un des
siens écouter sérieusement on sentait
une progression de marine le pen je suis
enfant voire les prochains sondages mais
son discours sur l'économie surtout sur
la monnaie européenne sérieusement c'est
pas crédible et je vois mal la fin si
vraiment haut rendement la donne à 40,1
euros un peu moins de quarante un peu
plus sérieusement si encore 40% de
français qui votent pour elle ou si
l'abstention est très forte c'est quand
même un problème parce que ça veut dire
que la colère d'un france est forte
parce que le niveau son niveau sur le
sur la monnaie européenne sérieusement
mais je comprends pas c'est heureusement
que qu'à ce niveau-là et puissant
qu'elle a perdu des électeurs elle a
perdu des voix hier soir moi qui suis
européen franchement quand je l'écouté
je vais écouter son sa thèse ainsi une
thèse qui plaide crédit mais
heureusement ce ca confuse en effet
actuelle sur les deux monnaies sur la
monnaie européenne sur l'euro ce rappel
si vous voulez de l'écu la thèse de
giscard mais qu'elle est au tout début
c'est duke a créé le sm et va prier il
est qu après il ya eu le franchement
c'était une confusion intellectuelle qui
est pas digne d'un candidat
croyez vous et moi j'ai tendance à
penser que les gens sérieux peuvent pas
sonné ce discours l'un peuvent pas
cautionner cette cette faiblesse
intellectuelle sur un sujet aussi majeur
et vous me disiez emmanuel macron lui
était plutôt approximatif sur le fond
souverain
non non ce der sar est un des problèmes
depuis toujours c'est qu'en france il
commencera très grand fonds souverain un
peu comme en norvège un peu commun
comme en arabie saoudite doit beaucoup
de grands pays des fonds souverains qui
protège les fonds de pension qui loge 10
heures de fonds de pension nous on a
refusé de faire des fonds de pension
balladur n'avait fait je sais pas la
supprimer
et c'est vrai que faire des fonds de
pension s'est en fait créer des fonds
des fonds souverains qui nous protège
alors l'ancien la question de marine le
pen qui manifestement mélange un peu
tout la réponse de mag ont été de dire
oui nous avons sur un l'ailé b pib pays
c'est pour interne c'est pas un fonds
souverain on a besoin d'un grand fonds
souverain qu'on n'a pas en france parce
qu'on a trop dépensé et qu'on appelle le
courage de faire ça que j'ai trouvé là
dessus un peu floue fin bon mais peu mis
les plus compétents que moi moi je ne
suis que c'est un parlementaire lula
tennis d'économies dont qu'il maîtrise
mieux que moi mais ça va quand même
surpris quelques mois maintenant sur les
législatives pour certains à droite on
les a entendus cette semaine je pense à
christian estrosi à xavier bertrand
la droite doit pouvoir gouverner avec
emmanuel macron est ce que les
centristes doivent également vous les
appelez à faire partie d'une la future
majorité présidentielle il ne faut pas
préjuger le vote des français
il ya d'abord le deuxième tour tdimanche
donc nouveau thomas cran et la plupart
d'ailleurs des des partis démocratiques
vote mac on appelle à voter mâcon après
vous avez des élections législatives un
premier tour un deuxième tour d'hôtel
est tout simple soit il menait le
maquereau qui sera très certainement je
pense le président élu m'enfin attendre
aux gammes de cette bio soir est élu
président la république et dans ces cas
là il arrive entre le premier et
deuxième tours obtenir une majorité de
ces candidats marche puisqu'il refuse
tous les autres et dans ces cas là
pendant cinq ans il dirigera le pays
avec ses candidats soit ils n'arrivent
pas à avoir de majorité
et c'est vrai que là où on rentrera dans
un processus je pense de recomposition
un processus de recovery sur l'addition
grande coalition petit peu comment 58 en
novembre 58 quand le général de gaulle
est arrivée la première
assemblée nationale d'enseignement
public est à 58 ou de gaulle n'a pas eu
de majorité de novembre 58 à 62 et là
c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir une
recomposition politique avec une coupure
peut être des républicains je ne sais
pas une coupure du parti socialiste les
udi modem et puis les en marche
merci beaucoup merci photo di borgo
d'avoir répondre à deux questions merci
beaucoup très bien merci au fait merci
beaucoup savaient rien pour cette
réaction directe et comment ce débat at
il été vécue par les électeurs de gauche
hamonistes et mélenchonistes qui
pourraient être tentés par l'abstention
ou le vote blanc
nelson gtn s'est rendu à la
bellevilloise à paris son reportage
j'ai beaucoup de choses contre le pen
donc je vois pas compte tout simplement
des électeurs de gauche et quelques
maquereaux nice thiers à la
bellevilloise à paris 300 personnes
s'étaient réunies pour regarder le débat
sur grand écran dans une atmosphère
festive
les spectateurs ont été surpris par la
brutalité de la confrontation
ça tape dur je pensais pas qu'ils aient
d'abord une agressivité aussi fort et
puis on rentre pas vraiment dans les
sujets là vous voyez sa part encore
punchline et où le plus de fonds la
salle on manque trop déçu par le fond du
débat
le public avait réservé quelques
sifflets pour marine le pen et des
applaudissements pour emmanuel macron
certains indécis ont même été étonné par
la performance du candidat dans marche
la crau j'ai toujours trouvé très
est très mauvais désormais très mauvais
en meeting moderne interwiew
ectoplasmique même inexistant voit mal
placé corp à présent et un creusement il
m'a surpris j'ai trouvé très à l'aise je
ne suis pas extrêmement enthousiaste
l'auteur emmanuel macron prix pour
autant je pense que je pense que c'est
juste une question à ce qu il faut même
espérer qu'on met à en croire le public
de la bellevilloise le débat d'hier soir
pourrait donc s'avérer décisif pour
dimanche mais qu'elle va metz nous a
rejoints sur ce plateau bonsoir
michaëlle jean est le politique à public
sénat
quelle impression michael vous a laissé
ce débat un goût amer très sincèrement
même avoir un sentiment de malaise
s'était je reprendrai les boues de
pierres qu'on vient de vendre leurs
reportages ça tape dur effectivement
pendant toute la soirée
ça a tapé très dur en 2002 jacques
chirac il avait refusé le débat par
crainte je cite de banalisation de la
haine et de l'intolérance du front
national alors est-ce qu'il fallait
débattre
sincèrement oui parce que vu aujourd'hui
la place qu'occupe le front national et
vu les scores que font que fait le front
national aujourd'hui ça serait
méconnaître et ne pas écouter la colère
des français simplement est ce que ça va
donner un avant goût de ce qui va se
passer dans la vie politique française à
partir de dimanche prochain
là ça serait quand même dangereux pour
la démocratie française et ça peut
laisser un goût amer aussi pour les
citoyens
et très sincèrement pour le débat
démocratique il y en a près okouya soit
parce qu'il ya quand même un vainqueur
et un vaincu dans ce débat oui on va
dire emmanuel macron au vu de la
violence de la charge contre lui et pas
forcément parce qu'il a réussi
l'étape hier soir du débat mais il est
passé pour le vainqueur
par rapport à une marine le pen parce
qu'il a réussi tout simplement à marquer
des points sur l'économie a marqué des
points sur l'europe alors oui il a pris
en défaut un vainqueur mais un vainqueur
extrêmement abîmées il a peut-être lui
réussi à endosser le costume mais même
la méthode de pilonnage de marine le pen
intensifs elle va forcément faire
forcément laissé des traces pour
emmanuel macron peu importe presque la
véracité des faits notamment quand elle
a parlé de lavande sfr de son soutien à
liu wei f l'impression de la vérité
finalement n'était pas la principale
préoccupation de marine le pen hier soir
et le but c'était tout simplement
d'affaiblir d'isoler de fragiliser
l'adversaire papa pour le battre
forcément simplement pour paraître
en quelque sorte comme la principale
opposante pour demain c'est comme si
quelque part elle avait acté quelque
part cette forme de défaite est elle
donc elle veut occuper cet espace
notamment c'est très clair vis-à-vis de
la droite ça va laisser des traces
encore aujourd'hui on l'a vu lors des
déplacements des manuels macron il est
obligé sur le terrain à albi de
désamorcer chaque élément notamment sur
la taxation financière auprès des
salariés non c'est son entame en songe
encore une fois il est obligé à chaque
fois de convaincre désamorcée et quelque
part ça le fragilise énormément à trois
jours du second tour la campagne est
aussi débordés au déborde sur le terrain
je discerne week-end oui on a entendu
aujourd'hui dans le débat hier soir et
aujourd'hui manuel macron marine le pen
hier soir qu'il le dit pendant le débat
et vous envoyez un compte offshore aux
bahamas s'est passé presque inaperçu et
puis ce matin on apprend qu'une série de
tweets hier soir en provenance des états
unis
relayé par la russie voyez ça ça
commence à sentir un petit peu pas très
bon de ce côté-là et évidemment emmanuel
macron qu'est-ce qui est obligé de faire
il saisit la justice
il porte plainte le parquet de paris
ouvre une enquête là encore une fois
obligé de désamorcer rappelez vous il ya
quelques temps il y avait eu des rumeurs
sur sa vie privée
il avait pris un peu par l'humour à
cette fois c'est du sérieux
merci beaucoup à mikel pour cette
analyse on revient à présent sur les
erreurs et les entendu des vallières
avec vous tam tran huy bonsoir c'est un
toc si on peut dire il y en a eu surtout
du côté de chez marine le pen
et oui on en a beaucoup parlé ça a été
un festival d'erreurs du côté de marine
le pen et ça a été largement commentée
depuis hier soir
alors parmi la grosse vingtaine d'
erreurs qui ont été commises je vais
mettre l'accent sur celle qui concerne
l'europe et la sortie de l'euro c'est
l'un des marqueurs du programme du front
national et là il ya effectivement eu
une scène d'anthologie
on la regarde tout de suite mais à quoi
c'est une mort est connue c'est un
panier de 2
de monnaie vous le savez encore une fois
alors ça existe et qu avant mais ça
existe et juste avant l'euro juste avant
que l'euro devienne notre monnaie bon
physique en france et oui et oui oui et
oui c'était l'euro déjà et avant lui
trotter l'écu donc les grandes
entreprises elles payer en euros en est
qu à 8,93 à 2002 toutes les entreprises
pouvaient payer les grandes entreprises
pouvaient payer effectivement en euros
ce système a parfaitement fonctionné
monsieur macro ne fait pas semblant de
ne pas le savoir non je savais très bien
il a fonctionné dans le cadre du sm e et
honnêtement 2,93 à 2002 c'était plutôt
performant la marine le pen mélange tout
alors on va essayer de reprendre un
petit peu les choses dans l'ordre le s
émeut dont elle parle le système
monétaire européen il a et court de 1979
aux années 90 c'est un système de
coopération européenne en matière de
taux de change
l'objectif est bien c'est de stabiliser
les monnaies européennes à l'époque le
franc la lyre ou encore le marque et
pour cela et bien on encadre leurs
fluctuations autour d'une monnaie
virtuelle les culés de lévis les devises
nationales doivent pas trop s'en écarter
et en clair et bien les culs ne
constituent en rien à l'époque une
monnaie commune c'est juste un outil
virtuel une unité de compte on peut
effectivement compter en écu mais en
aucun cas les entreprises ne peuvent
payer en écu ce n'est pas la seule
erreur à marine le pen notamment sur
l'europe elle a aussi dit que l'économie
britannique ne s'est jamais aussi bien
portée que depuis leur exil
ouais sauf que le parc site
effectivement il n'a pas encore eu lieu
et il n'a pas commencé l'article 50 qui
enclenche les négociations pour sortir
dans deux ans n'a été activé que le 29
mars dernier est d'ailleurs on commence
à voir un petit peu l'inquiétude des
britanniques qui commencent à impacter
la croissance britannique et notez
d'ailleurs que l'union européenne déjà
est en train de réclamer au royaume uni
de régler la facture on parle de 60 à
100 milliards d'euros et bayard de très
longues négociations pour savoir quelle
sera cette somme elle sera conséquente
est nécessairement elle impactera
l'économie britannique
il ya aussi cette déclaration votre
union européenne je cite ces neuf
milliards d'euros par an pour la france
et oui et là on va regarder en fait un
petit peu de matin si on regarde les
chiffres du parlement européen 2015 la
france à verser 19,1 milliards d'euros
au budget de l'union européenne mais
elle aperçut 14,47 milliards ce qui veut
dire que ça lui a coûté 80 63 milliards
j'ajoute les droits de douane les
cotisations sur le sucre qui sont
directement versés à l'union européenne
1,6 milliard et au total on arrive à un
peu plus de 6 milliards d'euros c'est à
dire la somme qu'a dit hier emmanuel
macron et enfin cette phrase n'est pas
une des français est en danger à cause
de la loi sur l'union bancaire et l'a
d'ailleurs on avait déjà parlé sur ce
plateau puisque cette phrase c'est
également celle qui avait dit jacques
cheminade alors la loi sur l'union
bancaire qui reprend une directive
européenne de 2015 prévoit bien la
possibilité de fonctionner les dépôts
des clients mais ils ne sont que le
troisième recours après les créanciers
après les actionnaires et puis les
dépôts jusqu'à 100000 euros sont tout de
même à garanti ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant donc c'est plutôt une avancée pour
ces épargnants et enfin je rappelle
qu'en cas de faillite des banques
auparavant et bien c'était l'état qui
devait renflouer les banques c'est à
dire tous les contribuables
emmanuel macron n'a donc commis aucune
erreur lors de ce débat selon vous ma
peu en économie dont il est spécialiste
mais tout de même sur le chômage il ya
eu des exagérations
par exemple lorsqu'il dit nous sommes le
seul pays d'europe à ne pas avoir
endiguer le chômage de masse quand il
dit ça eh bien ils oublient que
l'espagne est tout de même à 18 %
l'italie à 11 et demi pour cent que la
moyenne de la zone euro est quand même à
neuf et demi pour cent et que la france
n'est qu'à 10 % en revanche il a raison
encore un peu plus tard il dit qu'il y
avait plus de chômeurs dans les années
90 il fait référence à 1994 où le taux
était à 10 4 % si on prend les chômeurs
de catégorie a en revanche si vous
élargissez aux chômeurs de faible
activité bien aujourd'hui il y en a
quand même plus
d'autres erreurs des manuels macron
selon-vous tam et bien par exemple
lorsqu'il dit qu'il veut revenir sur la
loi qui a fait que pour toutes les
peines de moins de deux ans il n'ya pas
d'exécution de peine et qu'il attribue
d'ailleurs cette loi à christiane
taubira il ya déjà il ne faut pas
confondre exécution de peine et
aménagement de peine
ensuite d'un auparavant il est vrai qu'
on ne pouvait aménagé que les peines de
prison ferme deux mois d'un an
mais le sai a été remonté à 2 non pas
par la loi trop bien mais bien par la
loi
dati de 2009 c'est-à-dire sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
christiane taubira n'y est pour rien
mais la voix que poèmes emmanuel macron
comme marine le pen ont commis l erreur
en attribuant cette mesure à l'ancienne
garde des sceaux de françois hollande
merci beaucoup tam pour ces informations
est dans cette campagne d'entre deux
tours les deux candidats se sont
adressés aux indécis ils seront une des
clés du scrutin dimanche par miauler
primo votants ces jeunes qui ont voté
pour la première fois celle ci dessous
et géraldine beys ou alors sont allés à
leur rencontre à rennes et vous allez le
voir il reste encore pour le second tour
reportage ils ont entre 18 et 25 ans ils
sont étudiants ici à rennes ils ont voté
pour la première fois le 23 avril
dernier
comment ce que l'on appelle les primo
votants livres qu'ils les résultats du
premier tour
que vont ils faire au second tour nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre pour leur
demander
campus de rennes l'université en
sciences sociales accueille hommes 3000
étudiants quand on souvent dans la
bouche des électeurs du fn c'est qu'ils
vont dire par là essayer la droite on a
essayé la gauche aujourd'hui on va
essayer le fn passe en pleines
discussions politiques
on n'a pas essayé ça nous retrouvons
cindy clos et mathilde et marie quatre
étudiantes en histoire entre abstention
vote blanc ou vote macron pour le second
tour leurs avis divergent
elle supporte mal en tout cas les
discours culpabilisant honnêtement
aujourd'hui si marine le pen au second
tour c'est à cause des 21 % de personnes
qui l'ont mené là c'est pas à cause des
gens qui ont voté hamon qui ont voter
mélenchon qui ont voté fillon c'est à
cause des gens qui vont voter marine le
pen car il faut arrêter de culpabiliser
les gens on a on a un droit de vote et
on doit l'exercer en tant que tel on
doit pas juste le faire pour faire
barrage à quelqu'un nous avons aussi
rencontré ninon 22 ans
au premier tour elle a voté pour
philippe poutou
mais au second tour elle a décidé de
rester chez elle
impossible de voter marine le pen
impossible aussi de voter pour emmanuel
macron à qui elles attribuent la loi
travail contre laquelle elle s'est
engagée
je vais pas aller voter pour quelqu'un
que je déteste mais que je considère
avoir gâché la vie de milliers de
milliers de gens pour faire barrage à
quelqu'un
despotique marine le pen enfin c'est à
mon sens en fait on nous vante le
sacro-saint vote comme larmes
démocratique etc
mais déjà même la notion de vote utile
en fait ça rentre en contradiction avec
ses idéologues loups qui ont aussi à
manifester contre la loi travail mais
vote aura quand même
emmanuel macron bonjour loupian vous
avez 20 ans vous avez voté benoît hamon
au premier tour et au second tour vous
avez fait un choix est-ce que vous
pouvez nous l'expliqué pour un étudiant
qui s'est opposé à la loi travail comme
moi l'année dernière qui se retrouvent à
voter pour emmanuel macron le choix il
peut paraître illogique
enfin rappelé en août 2002 le choix il
était évident alors aujourd'hui a plus
l'effet surprise et qui est celui de
2002 il ya une banalisation des idées du
fn est aussi simplement du fait que le
fn fasse des très beaux scores mais le
danger il est toujours là autre parcours
autre préoccupation nous nous sommes
rendus dans un centre de formation pour
les moins de 26 ans ici les jeunes
participent à un programme d'insertion
vers l'emploi
le 23 avril ils pouvaient voter pour la
première fois mais la plupart ne l'ont
pas fait je me fais parce que je suis
connu en france une arène où il savait
pas si vous aussi vous êtes ici donc
j'ai pas fait
[Musique]
personnellement j'ai papoté ce que
j'avais deux autres choses des prévenus
ça vous intéresse
en fait c'est pour moi y'a aucun
politicien qui qui est correct entre m'a
prouvé le plein autant voter m'a pris
par le pen présent kimi lui à voter jean
luc mélenchon au second tour
il ira voter blanc vous aviez imaginé ne
pas voter comme la plupart de vos chanel
d'avis à chamel d'avis je préférais je
préfère mourir dans l'instant plutôt que
pas voter quelqu'un cas pas voter parce
que bon j'avais mieux à faire ce jour là
tu avais bien faire ce jour là tu
rigoles personne a mieux à faire ce jour
là que voter c'est ce que je pense qu'on
peut le faire par procuration moi je
peux je pourrais pas vous dire ce qu'on
tourne ma mère tu le feras ma passe tout
le monde peut voter
on fait partie de l'histoire qu'on va
voter c'est un simple bout de papier
qu'on met dans l'urne mais je pense
qu'on fait partie de l'histoire
faire partie de l'histoire mais aussi
décider de l'avenir
jimmy a un fils de quatre ans et c'est
promis qu'il se rend aux urnes dimanche
prochain
et à trois jours du second tour quelle
un enjeu dans cette campagne on va
revenir sur le débat a bien entendu mais
aussi sur les stratégies et développé
par les deux finalistes à cette
présidentielle dans notre débat s'est
tout de suite aimé invité sur ce plateau
crise telle que rappelée bonsoir vous
êtes la directrice de clientèle chez
l'institut de sondage bva opinion merci
d'être avec nous j'accueille également
laurent bouvet bonsoir politologue
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
sur ce plateau également dia jebrane
bonsoir vous êtes directeur conseil de
l' agence de communication en little
wing auteur du livre moi président des
couacs nicolas lebourg est également sur
ce plateau bonsoir vous êtes historien
spécialiste des droites extrêmes membre
de l'observatoire des radicalités
politique de la fondation jean jaurès
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
et jérémie manigne est également avec
mon bon soir on se serre président de
netino c'est une société spécialisée
dans la modération et l'analyse des
commentaires sur internet crise et le
rappeler on vient de le voir ce débat
était intense mais pour quelles
conséquences on sait que jusque là les
précédentes confrontations télévisée
n'avait pas vraiment influencé le
résultat dans les urnes
oui effectivement traditionnellement ça
assez peu d'importance et assez peu
d'effet surtout sur les sondages
là notre dernière mesure créditait
emmanuel macron de 60% des intentions de
vote
peut-être que compte tenu de la
spécificité de ce débat et du fait que
ça a pris quand même une tournure assez
agressive assez violente
ça peut avoir un effet l'avenir nous le
dira ouais
laurent bouvet on se demander si
emmanuel macron allait tenir le choc
face à marine le pen face à une
candidate réputé bien difficile dans les
débats finalement c'est lui qui a pris
l'avantagé hier soir oui il ya eu un
effectivement une surprise de ce point
de vue la france chez l'ensemble des
téléspectateurs puisque on n'avait
jamais vu emmanuel macron dans une
confrontation à intel en avec un tel
enjeu cela dit on n'avait pas vu non
plus marine le pen dans cette situation
donc c'était pour les deux quelque chose
d'inédit et on a vu effectivement il
marine le pen qui avait qui avait à
à attaquer je crois que ça a été ça dès
le début elle a commencé en attaquant
extrêmement fort parce que elle est dans
les sondages à 20.2 emmanuel macron donc
ccrl d'attaqué et le fait qu'elle
attaque et qu'en face elle se retrouve
face à une défense
effectivement très calme avec quelqu'un
qui est sur les questions économiques
extrêmement compétent qui n'a pas de qui
n'a pas besoin de ces fiches je crois
que cette différence de style dans la
manière de parler à partir de ces
dossiers on avait cette pile de dossiers
devant marine le pen et avec un emmanuel
macron qui devait avoir deux trois
fiches simplement qu'il a à peine
consulter a marqué tout de suite une
différence après sur d'autres enjeux il
a été un petit peu moins à l'aise plus
en retrait on a vu au milieu du débat
sur les questions régaliennes ou là elle
a poussé très fort où lui était sûr de
la politique publique lui elle était
sûre du vraiment de l'incarnation au
sens le plus la plus virulente 1,2 sur
sur un domaine qui la caractérise et qui
caractérise son parti son mouvement
politique
et puis à la fin on a vu qu'elle tenait
presque plus la distance qu'elle comme
si elle avait lâché prise et elle était
dans une forme de deux elle rigolait de
manière un petit peu moqueuse c'était
pas du tout présidentielle alors qu'on a
vu un emmanuel macron qui a terminé en
plaçant ses dernières interventions un
niveau de présidentiabilité si on veut
bien plus élevé je crois que c'est ça
pour mon père pour moi en tout cas les
trois moments un petit peu du débat
s'est adjugé bras vous êtes d'accord
avec un des enjeux aussi de ce débat
s'est montré cet aspect de
présidentialité des candidats a marqué
des points face à marine le pen sur cet
aspect oui complètement parce qu'on
s'imagine à la place d'emmanuel macron
avoir autant d' insulte de d'accusation
et c'est une aubaine a proférées à son
encontre
il aurait pu justement sortir de ses
gonds et on sentait que marine le pen
attendait justement ce moment là
puisqu'elle a à chaque fois qu'ils
s'énervent et un petit peu en tout cas
qu'il avait un ton qui monte funeka mais
vous calmez vous vous êtes trop nerveux
vous sentez qu'elle est préparée cette
phrase là pour justement le mettre en
défaut sur cette présidentialisation de
son personnage parce qu'effectivement
c'est andy mais un nouveau venu en
politique donc les besoins de ce débat
pour montrer qu'il était à l'aise à la
fois sur ces dossiers et puis en même
temps maîtrise de son de son attitude
nicolas lebourg ce débat était souvent
jugée 1 10
marine le pen porte certainement la
responsabilité de ce débat qui a tourné
en véritable pugilat ça a été rappelé
est-ce que c'est aussi le véritable
visage de l'extrême droite française
qu'on a pu voir hier selon vous il ya
deux aspects différents dans votre
question est ce que marine le pen et le
front national demeure un parti
d'extrême droite c'est une question
qu'on pose régulièrement oui l'extrême
droite c'est pas une gageure dans notre
vie politique ça existe depuis le 19e
siècle comme formule début 19e
ça correspond idéologiquement lit les
livres de marine le pen on lit des
choses qu'on lisait déjà au 19e siècle
dans ces courants là donc ça y'a pas y'a
pas de soucis sur cette question là ce
qu'on a vu hier c'est une tradition de
l'extrême droite française
le problème par delà c'est que marine le
pen ça fait un an et même plus depuis
les régionales quel sega des mauvais
reports de voix depuis la droite qu'elle
sait qu'elle a des mauvais vote sur le
csp + qu'elle sait qu'elle pénètre mal
sur le segment des retraités et c'était
tout cela qu'elle allait chercher elle
n'y est pas arrivé dans la campagne sort
du premier tour le stade que l'on a là
nous montre que sur les retraités que
sur ssb plus elle n'a pas progressé
on a eu ce méli mélo sur l'euro la
monnaie commune qui étaient censés les
rassurer et on arrive au débat d'hier si
le débat d'hier lui a permis de mieux
pénétrer les csp + et le retraité j'en
serais extrêmement étonné pour ma part
jérémie mani comment ça a été vécue par
les internautes est ce qu'un verdict on
parlait d'un un gagnant dans perdant qu
est ce qui ressort ce qui ressort de
façon très classique c'est le fameux
biais de confirmation
c'est à dire que si vous aviez
l'intention de voter marine le pen c'est
pas ce débat qui va forcément changer
les choses en tout cas dit autrement on
est tous très nombreux à dire que
emmanuel macron aurait gagné ce débat là
je peux vous assurer qu'à énormément de
militants sympathisants front national
qui considère que c'est marine le pen
est à gagner sans trop donner
d'arguments derrière mais qu'elle
considère néanmoins une fois que ceux ci
a été dit on constate quand même qu'il
ya un certain nombre
difficile à chiffrer de sympathisants de
militants front national dont le doute
est permis maintenant en tout cas qu'ils
ont considéré qu'elle avait raté son
débat beaucoup plus que dans l'autre
sens je n'ai pas lu j'ai dû et des
milliers de commentaires depuis hier
soir mais je n'ai pas lu 2
militant pro macron dire que il avait
raté son débat ça doit être des pros de
canam est rarissime
alors que l'on va voir y compris sur des
formes telles que discorde c'est à dire
des forums des patriotes au sila qui est
sûre discorde c'est à dire les militants
les vrais hardcore militants front
national qui vont militer sur les
réseaux sociaux de façon très organisée
y compris cela pour une partie en tout
cas on dit dès le débat qu'elle avait
été nul je cite que on se moquait d'elle
sur les réseaux sociaux on appelait à
fond regretter l'époque de jean marie le
pen qui lui dans les débats auraient
probablement je cite à nouveau gagner ce
débat et aurait été meilleur voir que
monsieur philippot qui est censé
apparemment être un meilleur des
batteurs selon eux à nouveau que marine
le pen d'oka c'est quand même ce regret
chez certains donc au final oui
probablement emmanuel macron qui gagne
ce débat tout à fait certain que
beaucoup de militants de marine le pen
garde la tête haute et disent que c'est
elle qui a gagné mais on sent quand même
que c'est un peu plus friable
alors on va continuer ce débat mais un
des angles d'attaqué choisi par la
candidate frontiste c'était l'héritage
des manuels macron l'héritage de
françois hollande
je vous propose de réécouter son
intervention monsieur le ministre de
l'économie
dois je dire monsieur le conseiller
auprès de monsieur hollande c'était
votre vision dont connu marché du
travail madame quatre ans et que vous
avez été conseiller économique de
françois hollande depuis deux ans
ministre mais si vous avez la recette
pour diminuer sur man en quoi est ce que
vous n'avez pas ces tactiques rénale
pour le croyant nous sommes candidats
réduire facilement parce que vous n'avez
pas fait profiter monsieur hollande de
vos recettes
mais parce que si vous n'avez pas de
recettes parce que vos résultats ont été
en l'occurrence extrêmement mauvais il
faut le dire en matière de chômage
alors pourquoi vous vous présenter à la
présidence de la république si comme la
seule vraie question qu'on doit poser
madame le pen
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que vos
stratégies mais c'est normal ça fait des
décennies que ça dure votre stratégie
c'est simplement de dire beaucoup de
mensonges et de dire tout ce qui ne va
pas dans le pays mais vous ne proposez
rien s'installera puis on a vu que cet
argument de l'héritage a difficilement
pris hier comment vous l'expliquez pas
parce qu'en fait elle l'a répété à
l'envi et au bout d'un moment on avait
le sentiment que c'était son seul
argument die
lui faisait remarquer mais développer
votre projet alizés mais vous êtes
socialiste vous êtes l'héritage
d'hollande
c'est un peu court alors ça s'adressait
probablement aux électeurs de françois
fillon pour montrer que finalement il
valait mieux pas qu'ils portent leurs
suffrages sur emmanuel macron mais
probablement que c'était un peu court et
que même ces derniers peuvent au
contraire avoir été un peu déroutés par
ses limites ou ses imprécisions sur son
programme économique est finalement
l'objectif qui était de séduire cette
partie de l'électorat il n'est pas sûr
qu'il a été remplie hier soir laurent
bouvet comme sarkozy l'avait fait en
2007 emmanuel macron a finalement réussi
à incarner et bien une certaine
alternance la rupture avec une période
qu'ils avaient en partie lui aussi
écrite
oui à laquelle il a participé ce il a
été secrétaire général adjoint à
l'elysée auprès de françois hollande
dans la première partie du quinquennat
puis évidemment ministre de l'économie
dans la dans la seconde elle lui
rappelle mais il faut bien voir que ça
s'inscrit dans un contexte où les
socialistes même est très largement la
gauche ont expliqué pendant des mois de
campagne que macro n'était pas de gauche
que c'était pas
un socialiste qui l'étaient pas et c'est
alors comme il ya plus de débat sur le
bilan puisque personne dans cette
campagne a assumé évidemment le bilan de
françois hollande pas plus macron que
benoît hamon évidemment donc du coup y'a
pas il n'a pas eu à à à défendre le
bilan à être en avant il a dit moi je
suis parti quand je n'étais plus
d'accord bon bâton qu'il a il a rompu
comme tous les gens qui ont participé
peu ou prou au gouvernement et aussi on
dit mais il n'est pas de gauche il n'est
pas socialiste ce n'est pas un vrai
temps il n'a pas cette difficulté donc
la marine le pen est effectivement elle
doit revenir de très loin pour expliquer
que c'est l'héritier d'un don qu'on a on
a un contexte qui explique ça et puis
ç'a très bien été dit est là elle a
répété ad nauseam est là elle a été sur
en fait quand on regarde bien ce débat
elle a été sur un tout petit stock
d'arguments qui étaient des arguments
extrêmement agressif
elle devait conquérir des parts de
marché supplémentaires si on veut parler
de cette manière et elle était sur un
tout petit stock d'arguments et derrière
elle avait pas beaucoup de biscuits on
s'aperçut que elle était peut-être un
petit peu juste aussi sur un certain
nombre de dossiers peut-être que florian
philippot dont on parlait tout à l'heure
a dit elle prépare ce débat depuis 20
ans on voit qui a compté pour elle c'est
le fait aussi de se faire l'écho de la
colère de l' angoisse et bien de ce
qu'elle veut séduire mais ça n'a pas
suffi pour persuader les spectateurs y a
non mais c'est vrai qu'on a vu que
l'épisode 2 de whirpool à amiens a quand
même cristalliser cette campagne d'entre
deux tours on a vu que c'était vraiment
un marqueur hier elle a l'art p t elle à
pied 5 comme arguments et on voit
quelques ça pas forcément pris parce que
manu m'accrochant à fait cette campagne
comme les et laurent bouvet dès le début
sur le fait qu' il n'avait pas une n'est
pas comptable du bilan
en revanche elle dit elle a peut être
associée franc est mal macron à françois
hollande pour s'adresser aux électeurs
de françois fillon mais aussi aux
acteurs de jean luc mélenchon qui
reproche à emad macron justement d'être
comptable d'une certaine politique
sociale libérale d'avoir justement
soutenu la loi elle comme riz qu'elle
appelle l loi macron donc on voit qui a
effectué on essaie de jouer sur les deux
électorats elle avait dossier une vidéo
ya pas si longtemps où elles
s'adressaient directement à la france
est soumise
donc on voit qu'elle essaie de jouer sur
les deux électorats un petit peu friable
où les reports de voix ne sont pas
forcément certains pré-mans le maquereau
pour justement maximiser ses chances
d'être de gagner dimanche prochain on va
parler de la caisse sans électeurs la
france est soumise
un nicolas lebourg on voit que c'est
aussi une stratégie du mensonge qui est
clairement développé par marine le pen a
été mise à l'épreuve rudement hier aussi
face et bien à toutes ces informations
erronées qui ont été démentie au fil de
ce débat par emmanuel macron le problème
de l'extrême-droite française c'est
qu'elle passe sa vie à citer à un
théoricien communiste italien parce que
ça fait très jolie qui s'appelle antonio
gramsci en disant il faut faire la
bataille culturelle le prennent ce
qu'ils ont pas lu gramsci qu'ils n'ont
pas compris il le cite c'est différent
l'idée de gramsci c'est que certains il
faut se battre sur les idées sur les
représentations mais avec l'idée qu'il
faut créer un bloc d'alliance entre des
groupes sociaux
or ça ils n'ont pas du tout saisi et le
problème c'est que les punchlines
qu'utilise marine le pen on dit au front
national toujours on fait de la bataille
culturelle en ce sens ça mais elles
construisent pas une alliance entre des
groupes sociaux il n'ya pas hier dans
les punchline qu'elle utilise dans les
faits que news qu'elle utilise quelque
chose qui construisent une offre
politique sérieusement ce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que le prêtre marine le
pen a cru qu'elle avait eu la pierre
philosophale et florian philippot
qu'elle a crédibilisé le parti et
pouvoir en faire vraiment une offre
politique
or le problème c'est que l'offre
politique économique du front national
devient aujourd'hui anne c'est pire
boulet quand on regarde marine le pen
aux élections présidentielles
chez les plus diplômés elle fait moins
que faisait son père faisait moins que
faisait jean marie le pen en 1988 chez
plus diplômés qui ne trouvent pas ce
programme crédible
donc ça fait qu'elle alterne
effectivement des choses des
commentaires sur les banquiers des faits
que news etc etc en fait ça trouble un
petit peu ce message d'un front national
professionnaliser hélas oui manière
nicolas lebourg évoquer cette question
des faits que news on peut voir une
certaine similitude avec ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis avec l'élection de
donald trump il a aussi dans le débat
face à hillary clinton
beaucoup pour employer cette stratégie
du mensonge est là et bien on savait
fonctionner oui mais peut-être qu'il
était préparé cette fois ci c'était plus
un effet de surprise donc c'est
évidemment une campagne très axé réseaux
sociaux au sens où tout son punch line
qu'on a évoqué on les ai déjà vu mille
fois sur les réseaux sociaux depuis des
semaines voire des mois
je pense qu emmanuel macron et son
équipe ont eu largement le temps de se
préparer à ça et il n'est pas tombé dans
le piège de d'essayer de de relever des
choses il a plutôt pris de la hauteur
d'ailleurs il ya un tweet qui a très
bien marché hier
qui dit grosso modo monsieur macron
c'est votre faute si d'un bol d'or est
mort à la fin d'harry potter vous étiez
ministre
à cette époque là et donc il le prenait
à chaque fois que je suis pas
responsable de tout j'étais ministre
certes mais pas de tous donc voilà une
rentrée par un peu l'ironie et l'humour
pour contrer ses punchlines là bon voilà
du coup ça n'a pas pris elle a agressé
d'emblée mais ça n'a pas pris
et comme on est resté sur la même
stratégie comme un boxeur qui essayent
de coincé dans les cordes son adversaire
sauf que il n'y allait pas dans les
cordes mais justement je propose de
réécouter une des interventions de
marine le pen
elle évoque et bien angela merkel cette
fois de toute façon la france sera
dirigée par une femme ce sera au mois ou
madame d'accord alors elle est là la
réalité arrêtée bien évidemment cumulé
l'arrivée heureusement a eu des
dirigeants visuel vous laisser le mais
je sais vous interrompue non mais non
c'est moi qui ai bien eu les dirigeants
visionnaires
le général de gaulle et le chancelier
adenauer ils ont su travailler ensemble
ils l'ont fait le avec il voulait plus
notre époque il ne lance effet le cpnsss
lane n'ont pas fonctionné tout au long
de cette émission et christelle ac
rappelé oui effectivement il ya eu un
peut-être un problème de conviction et
surtout quand même les français
attendaient un peu des détails sur les
propositions politiques c'est quand même
souvent l'objet de ces débats et là ça a
pu leur paraître du coup assez pauvre
puisque finalement elle ne détaillait
pas ses propositions quand elle le
faisait elle était mise face à ses
contradictions
emmanuel macron avait un peu plus de
temps finalement utiliser davantage son
temps pour pour davantage exposé ses
propositions
après il faut voir aussi si il arrivera
avoir convaincu sur ce sujet puisque ça
reste quand même sa faiblesse il ya une
grande partie de ses électeurs même
qu'ils votent pour lui
par défaut ou pour faire barrage au
front national tout l'enjeu pour lui
c'est d'arriver vraiment à convaincre
sur ses propositions pour générer
davantage un vote d'adhésion
ça sera effectivement un des enjeux
notamment de son discours peut-être ce
soir à albi alors en bout
comment ne pas être apparaître comme un
président par défaut
ça c'est l'enjeu en cas de victoire
d'emmanuel macron dimanche alors c'est
c'est effectivement très difficile il
est dans une situation où c'est très
paradoxal ce qui ce qui est en train
d'arriver dans la vie politique
française avec la victoire d'emmanuel
macron qu'on attend pour dimanche
sauf accident majeur d'ici là bon on ne
sait jamais mais enfin là le retard de
marine le pen est tel que on ne risque
pas grand-chose à prédire la sete
ces tissus le il et il a réussi un coup
extraordinaire dans la vie politique
française comme on n'en avait pas vu
depuis la 5ème république avec ce ce
jeune homme dans un pays où il faut
avoir été blanchi sous le harnais avoir
soit échoué plusieurs fois la
présidentielle soit comme nicolas
sarkozy et françois hollande première
première candidature première victoire
mais après bon un parcours politique
très riche des films des deux côtés donc
là il arrive il n'a jamais été élu
il est il était inconnu il ya encore
trois ans ils déboulent il crée son
mouvement
ex nihilo alors qu' il fallait
s'inscrire dans un mouvement il faut
avoir des militants il faut avoir un
parti des finances lui créé ça comme ça
etc
il élimine toutes les familles de la vie
politique française
une à une alors il bénéficie évidemment
toujours en politique c'est comme dans
la guerre il y a de la chance qui
intervient évidemment il a de la chance
mais il est il passe il passe entre les
gouttes son chemin il arrive il est là
mais évidemment c'est ça le paradoxe il
est certainement celui qui va arriver
comme président de la république le
moins bien élu du point de vue non pas
de son score mais du point de vue de
l'adhésion à son projet ça va être un
président non pas on peut pas dire que
c'est un présent par défaut parce que la
vème république ne nous dit pas ce qu'il
y a dans chaque l'intention qu'il ya
dans chaque bulletin de vote
enfin demande emmanuel macron mais il y
aura évidemment un défaut parce que
beaucoup de gens ça a très bien été dit
ne vont pas voter pour son projet alors
est ce que c'est un avantage ou un
inconvénient
comme on a vu que les deux précédents
présidents nicolas sarkozy et françois
hollande y avait une adhésion à la
rupture sarkozyste à la triangulation
sur le travail on s'en souvient sur la
nation etc
il avait piqué
si je me permets d électeurs à la fois
au front national est un peu à la gauche
donc il est il y arriver comme ça
françois hollande par rapport à sarkozy
est évidemment contre sarkozy donc sur
des projets forts sur une adhésion sur
quelque chose qui était voulue par la
droite par la gauche là on n'est pas
dans ce cas là est ce que ça ne lui
permettra pas de mieux réussir son
quinquennat que deux présidents élus
avec un fort taux d'adhésion
ça ça va être l'expérience que nous
allons vivre en direct en france dans
les cinq années qui viennent de
légitimité selon vous il ya deux gébrane
on voit aujourd'hui est bien une tribune
de françois ruffin dans le monde qui dit
eh bien vous êtes déjà à lire c'est un
président qui s'est déjà ali enfin il
faut s'y mettre c'est en perspective
avec la campagne pour les chétive qui va
commencer juste après l'élection
présidentielle juste après dimanche et
françois ruffin est candidat on voit
bien qu'à la marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon commence déjà à prévoir de
s'attribuer le rôle du premier opposant
au futur président la république mais je
pense qu'il ya deux choses c'est que
d'une part mais le croate a toujours été
malin pour désamorcer les pièges qu'on
lui tendait et à chaque fois qu'on
l'attendait un tournant de la vie
politique la russie justement à
surprendre et a montré qu'ils étaient
capables d'affronter une épreuve donc
comme laurent bouvet le disait peut-être
qu'il réussira encore une fois à déjouer
les pronostics on parle aujourd'hui du
viol d'un maquereau bashing alors même
qu'il n'est pas élu on l'a vu avec la
rotonde par exemple et d'autre part je
pense que les appels au vote utile qu'on
a vue de part et d'autre des de
l'échiquier politique n'aide pas non
plus emmanuel macron à fédérer à pour
importer l'adhésion le mot utile en plus
ces fermetures et des votes inutiles
dont je pense que c'est l'expression
plus qu'on utilise dans les médias ne
note pas non plus emmanuel macron a
construit sa légitimité en tant que
présente la future prison la république
éventuel nicolas lebourg escalade jouer
cette carte de chef de l'opposition à
venir et hier marine le pen selon vous
on est dans une situation délicate parce
que c'est une élection à huit tours à la
primaire de la droite on nous avait dit
ça sera le père de la république
résultats rappelez-vous les électeurs de
gauche discuté entre eux pour qui on
vote etc
bon c'était invraisemblable après on a
eu la primaire de la gauche c'était
particulier là on est on est et après
effectivement on ne sait pas aujourd'hui
on en a pour la première fois deux
candidats qui sont là qui n'ont jamais
été députée eux de leur vie qu'ils n'ont
pas de groupe parlementaire on est dans
une situation totalement invraisemblable
l'élection sera fini qu'au mois de juin
à partir de là en plus une situation
difficile on dit holland et le présente
plus impopulaire de la vème république
le président le plus impopulaire vème
république avant il s'appelle nicolas
sarkozy
il ya un risque qui s'appelle emmanuel
macron prochain il ya vrai délitement
des institutions une vraie difficulté
est dans cette situation totalement
instable
on comprend qu'avec information pourtant
il ya une responsabilité particulière
pour le prochain président de la
république qui devra faire baisser le
front national emmanuel macron est il
bien la personnalité politique la plus à
même justement de faire baisser le prix
national pour 105 ans je ne sommes par
contre ce dont je suis convaincu c'est
que pour marine le pen pour ses
électeurs pour son parti il est
extrêmement important de dépasser le cap
des 40 % de constituer sert le double de
ce qu'avait fait le jean marie le pen en
2002 des dans une position pour attaquer
les législatives en ayant leur réel
espoir d'avoir un groupe parlementaire
elle ne peut pas arriver au début de
l'été en dix ans on avait deux députés
in fine et on en a quatre les gars parce
qu'avec la pression depuis cinq ans le
storytelling café marine le pen et
florian philippot en disant nous allons
prendre le pouvoir nous le voulons nous
l'aurons il pourra pas y avoir une telle
déception pour son parti sans secousse
donc elle poussera au maximum pour être
là chef de l'opposition effectivement
est là parce que son destin personnel
qui se joue aussi bien sur jérémy magnon
ont parlé de ce président qui risquent
peut-être d'être mal élu dimanche ce
sentiment de haine aussi à l'encontre
d'emmanuel macro est ce que ca ressort
sur les réseaux clairement mais dès le
départ je serais tenté de dire qu'il
était idée le départ en tant que
banquier et fils 2
et en fait ont d'ailleurs reproché à la
fois d'être très à droite est très très
à gauche
selon de quel point de vue on se
positionner dans quelque part n'y a pas
d' effet déceptif pour le coup puisqu'il
est haï dès le départ est à la limite
même ses militants je le disais sur un
autre plateau ya un petit moment
non non pas ne le pousse pas avec autant
d'enthousiasmé que un militant pro
frontiste pousserait pousserez marine le
pen y ait une sorte de côté raisonnable
beaucoup disent finalement heureusement
qu'il est là parce que s'ils n'étaient
pas été là ce n'est pas créer son parti
on aurait probablement marine le pen en
tant que présidente on va pas refaire
l'histoire mais c'est voit difficilement
qui a repris la place qu'ils occupent la
place de l'homme neuf celui auquel on
est prêt à dire tiens bon tu n'en as pas
encore essayé c'est peut-être le dernier
recours avant l'extrême droite donc
quelque part il ya un côté un peu
désabusé déjà c'est peut-être sa chance
parce que voilà il n'y aura pas d' effet
déceptif il peut faire que mieux vu que
tout le monde attend qu'il se plante par
manque d'expérience
c'est quelque chose qui se mesure
également dans les intentions de vote
dans les sondages
justement ce sentiment est bien qu'il
pourrait être mal élu que cet ensemble
un président par défaut
marc effectivement comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure dans auprès de ses
électeurs il ya une partie qui nous
disent qu'ils votent par défaut ou pour
faire barrage au front national
mais c'est qu'ils m'ont même dans ses
traits d'image on a vu qu'ils aient son
image s'est dégradée par rapport à
ailleurs même ne serait-ce que quelques
mois aujourd'hui paraît sympathique
meilhon les gens se questionnent sur les
toffes et ce qu'il a vraiment l'étoffé
d'un président il est quand même il n'a
pas une très bonne image sur le fait
d'être proche des gens proches de leurs
préoccupations
donc on voit qu'il ya quand même un
certain nombre effectivement de
difficulté est alors que françois
hollande déjà n'avait eu qu'un état de
grâce très limité quelques mois dès la
rentrée s'était terminée là
effectivement on peut se dire qu'il
n'est même pas élu qu'il a déjà beaucoup
de critiques faudra avoir effectivement
si du coup ça peut jouer plutôt en sa
faveur parce qu'il créera - 2 déception
il aura quand même à sa charge de
refédérer les français de recréer un
élan parce que quand au fil des enquêtes
on s'aperçoit qu'ils sont quand même
extrêmement pessimiste quand on leur
demande leur état d'esprit à l'égard de
l'élection sont des mots très forts qui
ressortent le pessimisme la colère même
révolte et c'est pas bon pour dans un
pays il faut quand même voilà qui kir
feder et qui recrée un petit peu d'élan
positif des c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il
essaie de faire dans son discours mais
pour l'instant ils sortent quand même à
des difficultés à des français est très
très pessimiste raymond rose est
justement à crise elle rappelé dans cet
entre-deux-tours l'attitude des
électeurs de la france insoumise aura
été au centre de toutes les attentions
jean luc mélenchon nous dit qu'il votera
mais refuse de dire pour qui accusé
notamment de faire le jeu du front
national font à sauvages alors que les
soutiens de la france insoumise ont
choisi l'abstention et le vote blanc
dimanche face à marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon a refusé de donner une
consigne de vote
ce qui nous est demandé ce n'est pas un
vote anti fasciste ce n'est pas un vote
anti extrême droite ce que nous demande
monsieur macron il a dit non un vote
d'adhésion
vous comprenez non n'adhérons pas à ce
projet un positionnement qui contraste
avec celui adopté en 2002 à l'époque
jean luc mélenchon était catégorique je
te plaît mais votez pas possible
désormais jean luc mélenchon et ses
soutiens ont pris leurs distances avec
le front républicain une position
ambiguë qui leur attire le feu des
critiques
on ne comprend pas quand on voit
l'attitude de marine le pen hier soir
y'a pas photo personne n'est pour le ni
ni personne ne met à signaler enfin je
parle pas pour mes amis et je dis si
certains d'ailleurs m'avez fait
l'honneur ou avait fait l'honneur de
voter pour jean luc mélenchon et se
poser la question de voter pour le front
national je leur dis par votre
intermédiaire ne votez pas front
national en appelant à faire barrage
contre marine le pen sans appeler à
voter emmanuel macron jean luc mélenchon
espère maintenir la dynamique pour la
bataille des législatives la france
insoumise qu'on ne présentait des
candidats dans plus de 500
circonscription et les relations avec le
parti communiste sont tendues dans un
communiqué le mouvement de jean luc
mélenchon exige l'arrêt immédiat de
l'utilisation de la photo du leader de
la france a soumise par le pc laurent
bouvet on voit bien la difficulté pour
les électeurs pour jean luc mélenchon
qui veut capitaliser sur son score
quasiment 20% au premier tour il
refusent de soutenir ouvertement
emmanuel macron ça pourrait il a fait
venir pour les législatives
pourtant c'est une stratégie risquée
aussi le voit qu'il a été accusé de
faits qu'il est dans une position très
difficile à elle bon d'abord il ya une
grande déception parce que là bon ça
c'est quand même joué à pas grand chose
tout ça avec françois fillon puis avec
marine le pen on est dans des dents des
écarts très faibles donc il y avait
vraiment une
une telle dynamique de la campagne de
mélenchon 1 dans les quinze derniers
jours qu'il pensait vraiment pouvoir
être au second tour il a pris une
position que j'appellerais de précaution
de comme un principe de précaution pour
garder le plus unis possible cette
france insoumise qui n'est pas un parti
un qui est un mouvement
on a des mouvements c'est très
intéressant alors on va pas faire de
mise sur la tuer mais du point de vue de
l'évolution et partis politiques de la
manière dont s'organise la vie poli donc
c'est un mouvement dans lequel il y à un
parti très structurelles parti
communiste qui a immédiatement pris une
position en faveur du vote macron dès le
soir du premier tour on s'en souvient
c'est ça c'est les relations mélenchon
parti communiste sont très difficiles on
se rappelle qu'il a été candidat sans
demander son avis au parti communiste
il a pris de vitesse le parti communiste
pour ne pas avoir à subir ce qu'ils
avaient subi en 2012 donc il a un parti
et puis la d des adhérents directs on
aurait dit à une autre époque il a des
petits des petits groupuscules il a des
gens qui sont très très à gauche qui ne
veulent pas du pouvoir il
il a beaucoup de choses la france
insoumis et le référendum entre
guillemets qui ait lieu la la la
votation citoyenne pour décider quelle
sera la sienne
la consultation a bien montré qu'il y
avait une diversité très grande et donc
lui
son but c'est d'essayer de préserver au
maximum les options alors évidemment les
législatives on très difficile parce que
avec une telle diversité
on va avoir certainement d'aider des
effets de candidature on voit déjà que
le parti communiste prépare ses
législatives qui qui risque d'être une
deuxième déception donc là je reviens
sur mon propos du début pour tous ces
militants notamment des jeunes qu'il a
su séduire c'est la première fois qu'à
nouveau on l'a vu un petit peu avant
marché aussi aussi des jeunes c'est pas
les mêmes évidemment il ya un an front
national bien sûr tradition
ces trois types de jeunes très
différents mais il a su séduire des
jeunes ils assurent ramener des
catégories populaires qui ne votent plus
à gauche depuis un moment donc il
simplement il risque d'y avoir une
deuxième déception parce que ça va être
très très difficile pour les candidats
étiquette france insoumise d'être élu
député etc
donc on va voir l'art à quelque chose
qui qui pourrait s'effriter dans le
temps parce que la personnalité de
jean-luc mélenchon dans une
présidentielle a été le ciment un ciment
très puissant entre avec grâce à son
talent grâce à sa qualité de candidat
qui ne sera pas présent dans toutes les
circonscriptions
donc là ça va être je pense très
difficile pour la france un soumise dans
les semaines qui viennent
nicolas le voici encore des électeurs de
la france un sommet ce qui pourrait se
diriger vers marine le pen au second
tour
alors c'est très intéressant parce que
sont les données de l'ifop j'ai pas vu
fait votre institut vous me pardonnez
cette l'ifop dont je me souviens le du
lendemain du premier tour à hier on est
passé de 20 points d'intention à 13
points une baisse de 7 points
macron restant stable à peu près autour
de 50 ses 7 points partant vers
l'abstention et vera le vote blanc est
alors choses encore plus passionnante
quand on regarde les catégories d'âge ce
sont les gens qui vont voter blanc ou
qu'ils s'abstiennent ceux qui refusent
donc de choisir entre monsieur macro et
madame le pen
ce sont des gens qui était électeur en
2002 ce sont des gens qui ont fait le
front républicain en 2002 sans doute
qu'ils ont pu voter pour jacques chirac
et qui ont peut-être pu se dire ensuite
mon dieu tout ça pour ça est ce que
c'était vraiment utile et que c'était il
ya des vraies questions qui se posent là
d'un comportement de jean luc mélenchon
il heurte on voit bien ce aorte le plus
les gens qui ont plus une culture de
gauche classique même temps toute sa
campagne a été basée sur le principe de
rompre avec la culture de gauche
classique on range l'international
oranje le drapeau rouge en renta certain
nombre des référents et on essaie de
construire quelque chose d'autre donc ça
c'est intéressant dans tous les cas
voilà le vote des mélenchonistes pour
madame le pen sont les données de l'ifop
il avait 7 7 points en mettant des
données assez similaire on a
effectivement un peu moins de la moitié
des électeurs de jean luc mélenchon qui
se reportent quand même sur emmanuel
macron qui se distingue en cela donc
très clairement des personnes qui ont
voté dans le cadre de la consultation
insoumis on a un gros tiers un peu plus
qui va vers l'abstention et nous on
avait encore 18% avant donc c'est une
mesure qui date de avant le débat qui se
portaient sur sur marine le pen elle
leur a tendu la main d'henry n'est pas
meilleure notamment en parlant de la loi
travaillant l'écoutent essayer de faire
oublier que vous allez participer à un
gouvernement qui a mis en oeuvre la loi
elle comme rick a été une loi encore une
fois de précarisation du travail qui n'a
pas créé un emploi qui a créé un chômage
qui est encore plus important depuis que
vous êtes partis du gouvernement que
quand vous y est entré mais ça je vois
que vous refusé d'en assumer la
responsabilité de chômage implicite non
mais je note que vous refusez encore une
fois cette responsabilité donc les
mesures que vous préconisez aujourd'hui
c'est bon les a vus si vous nous dit on
va faire ça empire
et bien moi je dis qu'il faut évidemment
radicalement tourné le dos à cette
politique là et il faut enfin faire une
politique de protection
encore une fois des emplois et de
développement des tpe pme parce que ce
sont elles qui créent l'emploi dans
notre pays
les tpe pme qu'est ce qu'elle demande
vous avez été voir les chefs
d'entreprise ils veulent quoi plus de
visibilité
ils veulent pouvoir qu'ils soient tpe
pme entreprises de taille intermédiaire
c'est pas du tout les grands groupes qui
le demandent les grands groupes il gère
très bien la complexité cris s'en fiche
complètement
mais toutes ces entreprises de
l'entreprise d'un salarié jusqu'à 500
elles veulent quoi elles veulent plus
d'adaptation à leur réalité économique
une entreprise qui est dans le btp qui a
deux salariés elle n'a pas le même
quotidien qu'une startups du numérique
aucune entreprise qui a 500 salariés
dans l'automobile ce n'est pas la même
réalité et donc il faut leur laisser la
possibilité de négocier pour certaines
un accord majoritaire d'entreprise les
grands groupes seul le peuvent
aujourd'hui dans certaines circonstances
et ont sauvé des emplois
gibrat non on voit clairement dans la
description de marine le pen qu'elle
présente emmanuel macron comme le
candidat de la casse sociale de la
brutalité sociale de la précarisation là
aussi c'est un message aux électeurs de
la france un sommet selon vos envies
complètement elle sait très bien que
c'est une des choses qu'on reproche
justement emmanuel macron d'être se
tenant devant politique françois
hollande a mené dans les deux dernières
années de son quinquennat
plutôt sociale libérale et et jean luc
mélenchon d'ailleurs on
ex que je sais plus où jean luc
mélenchon disait que pour que les
insoumis puissent voter pour les mâles
mâcon il fallait qu'ils reviennent sur
sa proposition d'une loi travail bis ce
que justement emmanuel macron à chaque
fois on refuse de faire refusant de
rentrer dans le jeu du système de
négociation avec des appareils
politiques sur des accords de
gouvernement et marine le pen et c'est
justement aussi de l'entraîner de là
dedans en essayant de devoir 6-2 le
maître de le pousser dans ses
retranchements et voir s'il peut reculer
sur ses propositions là et on voit
qu'elle
quels qu'ils refusent de jeu de jouer à
ce jeu moi juste de manière provocatrice
par baur reports de voix que les que les
insoumis pourrait pourrait apporter à
marine le pen je suis un peu étonné
qu'on n'est pas une chose justement dans
la consultation entre les différents
réjouis exactement le pen n'était pas
dans les trois choix qui était proposé
aux insoumis la consultation
j'irai même année sur cette question
constitue à les électeurs de la france
et insoumise on voyait aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux
ce maître est bien en place une sorte de
hashtag ni le pen nuit macro ont relayé
par les étudiants les lycéens qui ont
été effectivement celui dans lequel peu
partout ces venues d'un peu partout
alors nous on n'a pas de chiffres à
donner par contre on a les verbatim les
commentaires qui viennent expliquer
pourquoi je passe de l'ain je bascule de
l'un à l'autre et c'est vrai que cette
frange là de deux militants qui déçus du
vin plutôt qu'ils venaient de mélenchon
et qu'ils étaient prêts à voter front
national
d'ailleurs qui au départ était probable
un front national qui ont finalement
changé d'avis pour voter au premier tour
mêlant chant puis qui reviennent à leurs
premières amours
il explique pourquoi le doute commence à
s'insinuer et alors ça fait que moins de
24 heures un que le débat est passé mais
on est passé d'un débat sur les valeurs
de ni nationalisme ni libéralisme un
débat sur la compétence et c'est pas
pareil je pense que ça changera et ça
fera changer les idées d'un certain
nombre de gens qui étaient pro front
national sans adhérer sur les valeurs
parce que autant les valeurs les mettait
dos à dos autant la compétence est plus
difficile de soutenir qu'on va aller
voter pour quelqu'un qui visiblement
selon beaucoup de gens n'est pas apparu
comme compétente maîtrisant ces dossiers
on rappelle la somme de dossiers on vera
pelle et les vins erreur en une heure
qui ont été faites tout ça ils
l'entendent et ça les rend plus
difficiles donc à chaque fois c'est je
voterai avec le bout des doigts
peut-être les pinces ou des gants comme
disait mélenchon en 2002 mais il
explique que
voilà c'est à cause de ça notamment de
ceux c'est le manque de compétences
perçu désormais et du fait qu'on ne
parle plus que de ça depuis moins de 24
heures qu'il risque finalement de soit
s'abstenir soit éventuellement de voter
macron en tout cas de retirer leur vote
à marine le pen françois là on a
d'ailleurs déclaré que l'ignorance de
marine le pen sur l'euro ne lui permet
pas d'être présidente de la république
le débat a révélé le projet non
seulement incohérent mais dangereux de
marine le pen vous avez pu aussi mesurer
peut-être dans les intentions de vote le
caractère président un siècle de chaque
candidat à l'issue de ce débat alors on
l'a pas fait à l'issue du débat on avait
fait avant effectivement on a
globalement des personnalités politiques
qui ont des mauvaise image auprès des
français emmanuel macron marine le pen
n'échappe pas forcément cette
généralisation
effectivement on n'avait qu'une minorité
de français qui considérait que emmanuel
macron avait l'étoffé d'un président
c'était quand même davantage que la
proportion de personnes qui pensaient la
même chose pour marine le pen
donc sur ce point il avait quand même
déjà un avantage à voir si celui ci va
se renforcer
l'issue de ce débat en revanche il avait
quand même un certain déficit sur la
notion de proximité de comprendre les
préoccupations des français où la marine
le pen même si elles n'étaient pas
majoritaires avec des scores meilleur qu
emmanuel macron donc on voit que lui
pour lui il ya une question de stature
qui va devoir développer mais il a un
peu plus d'atouts pour le moment sur ce
sujet c'est surtout en terme de
proximité avec notamment les classes
plus populaires qui va devoir voilà
travailler parce que pour l'instant il a
clairement déficit d'image dans ce
domaine là on va faire un autre tournage
et une petite parenthèse rapide mais
après le soutien comme très appuyé de
barack obama qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue qui est un soutien très avec
beaucoup de connivence et durera
longtemps dit j'ai appelé monsieur macro
ont fini par dire en marchant français
voilà c'est un appui fort donc on verra
si ça rehausse sa stature autant le
soutien d'angela merkel pouvait faire le
jouer le jeu bardon de de marine le pen
et parce que ça montre et la connivence
franco-allemande qu'elle dénonce autant
celui de barack obama est un poids lourd
qui donne un costume un peu plus épais à
emmanuel macron dans sa peau ce possible
stature présidentielle
laurent bouvet ont parlé de ce sentiment
et bien d'une candidate à l'ecoute qui
comprend les français c'est n'a
d'ailleurs pas un hasard si elle a
choisi de terminer bien ses meetings par
la somme c'est une campagne sur la
france des oubliés sur cette stratégie
du front national elle ce qu'elle aura
quand même porté ses fruits puisque
marine le pen est quand même au second
tour d'une élection présidentielle
verdier la somme supérieure il ya
quelque chose qui est amusant sur la
somme qu'on peut rappeler deux secondes
en 2002 je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de sa un des signes
avant-coureurs que lionel jospin va être
éliminé après coup évidemment quand on
regarde les choses
après coup c'est la sphère des
inondations de la somme avec une folle
rumeur qui fait que monsieur jospin est
pris à partie par des gens ont dit s'il
ya eu des inondations
c'est parce qu'en fait c'est des eaux
que vous avez enlevé paris vous avez
envoyé vers la somme de manière à ce que
les parisiens voilà reste au sec et ça
veut dire beaucoup de choses cette
manière d'ennuis aux territoires hors
paris pour laisser paris au sec et c'est
à dire beaucoup de choses sur les
tensions qui a dans ce pays qui nous
expliquait le 21 avril en 2002 qui nous
explique le prince madame le pen là et
lui pardon lui était allé voir les
inonder de la sorte doublée d'un père et
c'est avec ses bottes sur les planches
et il ya vu une dame une pauvre dame je
me rappelle de cette image devant sa
maison ni monde et qui avait de l'eau
jusque là elle avait les cuissardes et
elle était comme ça ils étaient en
surplomb et puis la dame lui dise
exactement ça vous nous avez noyer pour
sauver pas risquer moins d'huile
hydraulique n'est pas possible mais peu
importe c'était et lionel jospin en bon
rationaliste lui disais mais madame ce
que vous dites c'est impossible ne dit
pas de bêtise et la dame était avec de
l'eau jusque là lui premier ministre au
sec d'en haut lui disais mais madame
voilà donc là il y avait c'était c'était
une des images de l'irena just
absolument terrible dans cette campagne
ratée de
alors quand la peur de ce qu'il faut
bien voir ce qu'ils essayent de jouer
marine le pen c'est un jeu qui date
depuis le début des années 90 depuis
après la chute du mur du berlin ou au
front national il ya cette idée de on va
faire exploser le clivage droite gauche
en imposant un clivage les patriots
contre les mondialistes
alors vous comprenez bien l'intérêt si
on dit qu'il ya plus de clivage droite
gauche comme une partie de la presse le
fait depuis 15 jours en disant c'est la
france du non la france du oui en
reprenant les éléments de langage de
marine le pen
ça veut dire qu'ils appuient d'extrême
droite et c'est très important pour le
front national d'en finir avec cette
étiquette d'extrême droite c'est pour ça
qu'ils appuient autant le rêve du front
national c'est de réussir
effectivement à fédérer la france du non
tant les nationalistes que les anti
libéraux de gauche etc
en pouvant transformer skins sociologie
électorale effectivement on a vu que sur
le vote macron le pen des différents
selon l'habitat selon le diplôme etc
mais transformer ce qu une sociologie
une géographie en descendant c'est pas
la sociologie ce pas la géographie de
l'idéologie et cette idéologie là c'est
celle qui peut ne pas madame au pouvoir
mais c'est peut-être une stratégie
géniale le seul problème c'est qu'elles
datent d'il ya trente ans donc
manifestement n'est pas facile à
appliquer pourtant si on suit votre
théorie mais magna macro était le
candidat idéal à affronter pour marine
le pen le mondialiste face à la
souveraine
oui c'est vrai que la peau sur des
matelas kron qui se dit aussi autiste
aime et qu'elle essaie d'installer un
autre clivage entre progressistes et
conservateurs pour cent je pense qu'une
que françois fillon serait plutôt son
adversaire ça est absurde et macron
était une cible un peu facile pour
marine le pen
mais je pense que là aussi beaucoup
péché par son impréparation par sa non
maîtrisée dossier par son attitude aussi
très agressive qui a justement
cast est un petit peu 7,7 la pertinence
de son attaque par rapport aux
mondialistes dont je pense que le font
effectivement elle aurait plié jouer sur
ce terrain là mais la forme et on voit
qu'elle aime fait une très mauvaise
campagne de premier tour et un
frémissement entre les deux tours avec
mr poulet etc
mais elle a fait une très mauvaise
campagne présidentielle malgré toute
attente effectivement je pense que la
forme a complètement miné le fond et sur
cette campagne d'entre deux tours
puisque emmanuel macron avait une
campagne un début raté un ça commence
dans la séquence rotonde
on voit rien
les atermoiements au niveau de son
entourage a démarré et en fait marine le
pen lui a fourni le l'étincelle du
démarrage parce que ce qui était prévu
hour le pool de sa discussion avec
l'intersyndicale le fait qu'elles
qu'elles aillent de manière totalement
impromptue faire un happening sur le
parking de whirlpool en faisant des
selphy et cetera fait qu emmanuel macron
sort de sa réunion avec l'intersyndicale
perdant de la séquence parce que lui
était enfermé marine le pen lui dit oui
vas manger comme ça dans son coin il
était à larrau tendance était pas
terrible
et là il va au contact il se fait huer
il rentre dans l'entreprise et là il
reste 10 buts et quand ils repartent pas
si vous avez remarqué
personne ne lui ces derniers il dit
quelque chose ça ramène aussi à la
campagne de 2002 à lionel jospin
l'état ne peut pas tout grandes phrases
terribles de lionel jospin simplement
lionel jospin en 2002 quand il dit
l'état ne peut pas tout ça s'arrête là
et tout le monde se dit mais c'est quoi
la gauche qu'est ce qu'il faisait nuit
et il ne les explique pas ce que fait
manuel macro ouvrier doit le pool il
leur dit l'état ne peut pas tout je ne
pourrais pas je ne peux pas vous
promettre des choses que je ne pourrais
pas tenir il fait aussi du contre
sarkozy à hayange et du con tre hollande
sur la camionnette à florange pour ne
pas avoir dans un encan walpole va
fermer les mêmes problèmes
mais il explique pourquoi l'état ne peut
pas tout il est le pédagogue il est
celui qui vient expliquer face à des
gens qui n'en peuvent plus qui vont
perdre leur boulot
voilà ce qu'on peut faire mais moi je ne
peux pas vous promettre que je ne
pourrais pas faire et ça là dessus ils
gagnent en compétences ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure que l'on se dit bon on
aime peut-être pas c'est peut-être pas
on va voter quand même le pen parce que
bon tout ça mais enfin quand même le
type bien là et 10 voilà voilà ce que le
pédagogue face à la démagogie une
opposition très clivée quelque chose qui
se ressent aussi dans les sondages alors
dans les sondages c'est plus difficile à
mesurer effectivement mais effectivement
on a remarqué que les manuels macron est
insistez beaucoup sur sur ces éléments
l'un refusait de faire des promesses qui
après la et langages et surtout si voilà
la réalité faisait qu'il ne pourrait pas
les tenir
ça c'est un discours qui peut
effectivement porter qui est quand même
à double tranchant parce que pour
l'instant balayé forcément les
aussi envie d'être séduit et c'est moins
facile à entendre ça n'a pas d'histoire
60% candidats ils seraient ils seraient
à 52 ans et puis le pendant négatif
c'est que voilà il manque aussi une
mesure forte qu'on retient de manière
très comme l'avait été la les heures
supplémentaires en 2007 et du coude à
force d'avoir un discours très rationnel
du coup forcément il n'a pas cette
mesure
mais voilà ils cherchent pas mais il a
plus de mal mais ses militants le dise
fofolle et surtout pas faire d'erreur va
essayer de chercher quelque chose qui
donnerait le bâton pour se faire battre
au cas où la mesure soit exactement pour
ça que par rapport ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure sur son quinquennat quelqu'un
qui arrive qu il et kim qui ne fait pas
rêver qui n'est pas dans la rupture qui
n'est pas dans l'espoir peut-être que
finalement ça va être positif pour lui
parce que le jour où ça va mal ou world
poule ferme personne va lui reprocher
d'avoir menti d'avoir dit n'importe quoi
donc il va pouvoir gérer les choses en
apparaissant comme le type qui le pipe
le président pardon c'est via ce moment
là qu'ils qui réussit quand même à à
faire changer les choses qui réussit à
trouver des solutions
hélas apparaître comme quelqu'un
finalement qui est beaucoup plus
efficace que quelqu'un qui aurait promis
et ne tient pas jarry mélanie on voit
aussi en cette fin de campagne
elle va se jouer sur le terrain
judiciaire avec cette annonce faite hier
par marine le pen de comptes off shore
une information très vite relayé sur les
réseaux sociaux
quel rôle ont-ils eu dans cette course
est jésus il manque alors les réseaux
sociaux dont j'ai géré venir mais ce
point s'il assure la fête new sur les
comptes offshore s'étaient vus comme une
catastrophe
les sources viennent de deux sources ont
relativement nauséabonde ça passe par
les etats-unis la russie ça paraît
crédible du tout chante déjà été
probablement mais mais en tout cas voilà
ça tombe un peu comme un cheveu sur la
soupe ça semble être la dernière chance
et j'ai l'impression que même dans son
camp on n'y croit pas donc tout cas les
militants que s'expriment 10 secondes
cela on va essayer de le relayer mais on
ne sent pas l' enthousiasme pour aller
pousser l'information sur les réseaux
sociaux
essayer de faire changer obtient donc
voila c'était une cartouche cartouches
mouillé dans les réseaux sociaux ça a
joué je pense que ça a joué parce que on
l'a vu hélas le débat était très
agressif mais parce
toute la campagne était agressive et
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux on
s'est battus que à coup de punch line je
pense que la force de front national sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est qu'un ils sont
très organisés et 2 les 140 caractères
de twitter c'est parfait quand on est un
peu démagogues parce que c'est facile de
dire il suffit de sortir de l'euro aura
le no problem paf se tient en 140
caractères pour contredire cet argument
là il en faut beaucoup plus que 140
c'est plus compliqué et ça demande un
peu de pédagogie mais là pour la
première fois il avait marine le pen
n'avait pas face à elle un journaliste
qui n'est pas censé faire le débat est
donc qui lui sert la question est qui
prend la réponse
il avait un contradicteur qui a eu le
temps en une heure et quelques de
démonter chaque argument et on a vu que
ça marchait
donc c'était une erreur de ne pas
essayer de rentrer dans le plus dans son
débat et désire reprendre à nouveau les
mêmes punchline qu'on avait tous déjà vu
the german sur ce rôle des réseaux
sociaux notamment et bien d'extrême
droite très puissant sur internet sur
twitter sur facebook est ce qu'ils ont
eu un rôle particulier dans cette
campagne
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont eu un rôle
de défouloir parce que je pense que
beaucoup de gens étaient frustrés de la
qualité du débat et puis du fait qu'ils
avaient quelques fournie sur le plateau
je pense qu'il ya déjà eu un rôle de
défouloir pour tous les gens qui
s'intéressent à politique et qui ont été
très déçus au-delà du débat dans cette
campagne et la préfecture à cette
campagne ça a permis justement de
véhicules est à la fois des faits que
nous mais aussi des vrais arguments avec
des vraies stratégies de riposte côté
mise en place par les différents
mouvements au parti donc je pense que
les réseaux sociaux déjà depuis 2008 aux
états unis barack obama 2012 avec la
stratégie très proactive de françois
hollande sur les réseaux sociaux
cette année je pense qu'on a vu toute
l'ampleur on se rappelle aussi c'est pas
vraiment un social mais la chaîne
youtube de jean luc mélenchon qui a été
après répliqué par florian philippot
avec beaucoup moins de succès mais en
tout cas ça a permis justement de
s'affranchir des médias si on n'était
pas invitée sur les plateaux télé ça
permettait justement de créer un canal
direct entre les militants les
sympathisants et les hommes politiques
juste part pour l'afrique nous
on se rappelle aussi que ça te fait que
nous avait déjà circulé une semaine
avant le premier tour il y avait déjà
été démenties ont dit que le canard
allait sortir mercredi à manger et où
nicolas lebourg sur l'aspect réseaux
sociaux notamment
est ce qu'on appelle parfois la
fachosphère oui mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en même temps la
chaîne jean luc mélenchon a très bien
fonctionné mais en même temps six
meetings el alami lieu les meetings on
pourra dire c'est la politique comme il
ya des décennies ont été absolument
extraordinaire en avion c'est en force à
renouveler les choses
ça a été une campagne assez vivante
alors après c'est vrai que l'effet que
nous c'est devenu vraiment quelque chose
de permanent
j'ai vu l'autre jour l'un des
journalistes des décodeurs et je conseil
a voté les spectateurs de ce d'utiliser
les décodeurs du monde pour détecter les
faits que nous qui a montré une la fecq
nous c'était emmanuel macron a choisi
manuel valls comme premier ministre
évidemment l'idée vous démobilisez les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon au
maximum en agitant pour le drapeau
absolue dont ça nourrit effectivement le
débat et on voit bien qu au delà l'idée
au départ de ce qu'on appelle jeu
souvent la fachosphère qui préférerait
évidemment elle même sapée la
réinfosphère à ça c'est de bonne guerre
l'idée c'est de remplacer les médias
l'idée c'est de détruire la réputation
des médias de manière systématique ce
n'est pas d'être un complément
d'information ces deux les remplacer
c'est de les tuer et ça c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui l'a en
termes de bataille culturelle est
quelque chose de bien penser de biens
construits il ya en france des gens
comme jean yves le gallou qu'un
intellectuel d'extrême droite qui a
engagé en politique de très longtemps
qui est un homme qui a des idées assez
radicale mais qui n'en sommes qu'à un
certain niveau intellectuel un qui a une
capacité à penser des stratégies et lui
ça fait plus de dix ans qu'il est sur
cette idée là sur la construction de ce
qu'il appelle donc lui la réinfosphère
et je crois que ça un vrai fait
aujourd'hui dans le débat public
ils ont gagné sa bataille culturelle rtt
zoom oui c'est vrai parce qu'il suffit
de regarder tous les articles de la
presse notamment en ligne qui disent que
c'est emmanuel macron qui a gagné cette
élection
vous allez voir que systématiquement le
média va se faire attaquer encore un
journaliste pro mac ont encore un média
pro mâcon c'est normal que vous pensiez
que alors même donc les médias société
quattron qui sont les amis de macron qui
sont qui tiennent les groupes de presse
ont il a été cité par marine le pen hier
soir évidemment dry bfm là c'est donc on
voit bien que qui a pris les modérateurs
derrière l'idée de du capitalisme des
banquiers 17 ans et toutous se bouclent
un cc très bien fait effectivement du
point de vue de la guérilla du match et
oui il joue aussi sur la défiance
grandissante des français qu'on mesure
la dans les enquêtes à l'égard des
médias traditionnels des journalistes et
du coup ils s'appuient sur voilà une
défiance aussi forte dans l'opinion sur
ce sujet alors on a parlé en du
casse-tête des mélenchonistes que les
conséquences sont aussi tangible pour le
party les républicains car vous allez
voir les stratégies divergent sur
l'attitude à adopter pour le second tour
soutenir ou pas emmanuel macron le débat
fragilise une droite déjà affaibli par
la défaite de françois fillon
mounir sont si au soir de sa défaite
sans hésiter françois fillon appelle à
voter pour emmanuel macron une
résolution qui tranche avec les
atermoiements qui ont agité son parti
dans les jours suivants face au front
national
l'abstention ne peut être un choix
nous appelons à voter contre marine le
pen
lr n'appellent pas formellement à voter
emmanuel macron pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite
une posture qui fuit sur l'unité de la
famille des personnalités comme bruno le
maire alain juppé xavier bertrand
christian estrosi françois baroin et
même nicolas sarkozy annonce qu'ils
voteront macron sans état d'âme
ils ne sont pas les seuls votre hamac
rond par défaut
totalement par des ya pas de campagne
pour macro n'y a pas de soutien mâcon il
n'y a pas d'alliance avec mâcon ils sont
combien candidats yann ac2 si vous dites
faire battre le front national temps
revient quand même bien à dire que c'est
ma grande d où il joue et 10 pour une
frange du parti
cette stratégie est suicidaire en vue
des législatives au nom de la cohérence
laurent wauquiez eric ciotti georges
fenech
nadine morano et pierre lellouche refuse
de demander aux électeurs de droite de
voter macron et le combat c'est macron
c'est pas aujourd'hui qu'il va falloir
tracté pour mac ont jusqu'au 7 mai c'est
pas possible je peux pas j'ai des
désaccords absolument fondamentaux avec
lui sur un certain nombre de sujets
majeurs
pierre lellouche a depuis claqué la
porte de son parti ait quitté la vie
politique mais dans l'hypothèse d'une
victoire d' emmanuel macron une partie
des républicains ne ferme aucune porte
françois baroin se prépare à matignon en
cas de cohabitation pour une eau le
maire se dit prêt à travailler avec lui
et les juppéiste n'insultent pas
l'avenir nous ne pourrons pas ignorer le
résultat de la présidentielle et nous
opposer surtout ce serait destructeur au
moment où la france a besoin de réformes
le ton du débat d'entre deux tours à
conforter les partisans du vote macron à
droite sur twitter gérald darmanin réagi
comment peut-on encore proposé le vote
blanc ou l'abstention après avoir vu
cela et alain juppé lance un dernier
appel
maintenant il va falloir voter je le
répète avec solennité s'abstenir ou
voter blanc
c'est faire le jeu du fn un message
adressé à tous les électeurs et surtout
à ses partenaires et l'eire qui refusent
toujours d'assumer un vote pour le
candidat face à marine le pen
reste à le rappeler que disent les
reports de voix les intentions de vote
chez les électeurs fillonniste vont-ils
se prononcer pour une abstention et un
vote blanc ou pour un vote macron à lors
de notre dernier à mesure on a presque
la moitié des électeurs de françois
fillon 46 % qui nous disent qu'ils vont
voter emmanuel macron donc qu'ils se
reportent largement enfin
majoritairement sur lui on a quand même
31% presque un tiers qui disent au
contraire qu'ils vont voter pour marine
le pen donc ce qui traduit quand même
les divisions au sein de cet électorat
et l'attirance pour une partie de
ses électeurs pour marine le pen et puis
on a 23 % donc un car qui va vers le
vote blanc ou vert l'abstention et qui
refuse de choisir
donc même si on a une petite majorité
vers emmanuel macron on voit bien quand
même les divisions qui s'exprime aussi
bien chez les électeurs de françois
fillon ont parlé des difficultés de jean
luc mélenchon se sont quasiment les
mêmes qui frappe le parti des
républicains laurent bouvet mais on voit
que cette élection a bouleversé a fait
cuire bull et c'était l'expression
utilisée par jean pierre chevènement en
2002 le système politique français
tous les partis sont touchés on parlait
tout à l'heure de la difficulté que
risquent d'avoir marine le pen si le
score n'est pas celui espéré
bon le parti socialiste a été est
quasiment éliminée au premier tour on
voit que on a parlé de mélenchon on voit
les républicains la question chez les
républicains va être je dirais c'est un
peu ridicule de dire ça mais c'est
presque encore plus grave que pourquoi
pierre luc mélenchon à la française
pourquoi les républicains parce qu'ils
avaient élection gagnée rappelons-nous
six mois en arrière bon l'élection
imperdable
ils perdent l'élection imperdable avec
bon candidat fillon tout le monde sait
ce qu'il lui est arrivé pourquoi tant
ils ont gagné pendant cinq ans pendant
tout le quinquennat toutes les élections
intermédiaires
vous avez ils ont remplacé la france qui
était devenu pendant dix ans une france
plus tôt avec des élus de gauche
socialistes et majorité et c'est partout
dans les villes dans les régions etc
et normalement les législatives qui
arrivent sont un couronnement car une
circonscription législative qu'est ce
que c'est ce sont des villes ce sont des
cantons ça c'est dans une région est
évidemment quand vous avez des élus
quand vous avez un maillage quand vous
avez des gens pour faire campagne et
c'est un parti avec beaucoup d'élus de
l'argent qui va avec et c'est vous avez
de bonnes chances d'avoir de gagner les
élections législatives là ils sont dans
une grande difficulté le l'offensive
macron les divise profondément certains
pensent ça n'a pas été cité dans votre
sujet mais éventuellement à se déclarer
dès après la présidentielle pour
rejoindre ce qui serait peut-être la
majorité présentielle autour de madaba
entre coalition cohabitation
alors qu'il devait être le parti de
l'alternance
après françois hollande quelques tous
convergé vers ça donc ils sont dans une
dans un moment historique où on peut
avoir comme il ya une division de la
gauche qui risque d'avoir une division
du parti socialiste il pourrait y avoir
une division de la droite et du parti
qui a été créée depuis le début des
années 2000 depuis l'ump pour réunir les
l'ensemble des familles de droite
on n'a pas parlé non plus du ralliement
de nicolas dupont aignan à marine le pen
ce sera son premier ministre en cas
d'élections c'est ce qu'elle a annoncé
est-ce que ça participe aussi ce
ralliement peut-être la banalisation la
dédiabolisation si elles existent du
front national le front national adore
ça ils appellent toujours ça des prises
de guerre alors c'est la même expression
que soit franck de la personne nicolas
dupont aignan l'arrivée de les poster le
premier ça des qualités s'est montrée
vous voyez nous ne sommes pas totalement
isolée ça permet de vous ramener dans le
bloc des droites faut pas oublier que la
stratégie ni droite ni gauche qui avait
inventé samuel maréchal c'est pour
théoriser isolement à un moment où
justement la droite ne veut plus du tout
passé d'alliance avec le front national
ou en même temps la sociologie
électorale montre qu'il ya eu beaucoup
plus d'ouvriers et de chômeurs qui ont
voté fn qu'avant et que samuel maréchal
à l'idée de théoriser cet isolement d'en
bas c'est pas qu'on est tout seul c'est
qu'on est contre tous les autres ni
droite ni gauche la situation voilà ça
permet de vous ramener dans le bloc des
droites
or le front social est dans le marché de
droite on l'avait constaté aux
municipales en aval à dessin avec le
politiste joël gombin on voyait très
bien par an que sur un second tour sur
une ville à gauche
votre électorat fn s'ils voient que
c'est prenable par la droite il lâche le
candidat fn au second tour ils votent à
droite
ce qu'il veut c'est d'abord se
débarrasser la gauche le vote fn il au
sein du marché de droite marine le pen a
deux fantasmes c'est dépassé donc le
marché les droites pour être ni droite
ni gauche parce que c'est la culture
fondamentale de l'extrême droite
française et donc d'assad avoir des
prises de guerre quels plusieurs vous
voyez bien monsieur martel monsieur
philippe au monsieur dupont-aignan ce
sont des hainard c'est bien et donc la
preuve que nous mêmes nous sommes des
gens sérieux que nous pouvons diriger le
pays maintenant est ce que nicolas
dupont aignan ça représente de folles
masse
en france comme au premier tour dia
jebrane avant de conclure ce débat c'est
vrai que ça aussi peut-être fait tomber
une digue
ce ralliement de nicolas dupont aignan
c'est un impact sur l'image du front
national oui complètement puisqu'on a vu
on a ces images en tête de samedi
dernier où elle s'affiche justement dans
un décor très solennel où elle signe un
accord de gouvernement où elle parle
pour un faute d'avoir un premier
ministre
donc elle se projette directement donc
dans l'imaginaire des français on peut
imager justement cette transposition de
marine le pen à l'elysée ce qui l'a
présidentialise le débat d'hier et
l'image qu'elle a pu donner je pense à k
c'est justement l'effet qu'elle a pu
avoir pendant ces premiers jours de la
campagne d'entre deux tours et puis
effectivement je pense que certaines
personnes à droite aurait pu être tenté
un moment de rejoindre l'aventuré front
national parce qu'ils sentent plus à
l'aise aujourd'hui avec certaines idées
du front national par rapport à une
droite plus modérée pas sûr encore une
fois que le débat d'hier et contribué à
constituer cette image on a un peu la
pression marine le pen a dilapidé son
capital qu'elle avait acquis pendant ces
quelques jours
même sentiment jérémy mieux manille
c'est vrai que nicolas dupont aignan
c'était avant le débat elle a perdu des
points avec ce débat mais commence avait
été perçue justement sur les réseaux
sociaux ce ralliement de nicolas dupont
aignan mais il faut se garder pas parler
les premières jours une première journée
surprise il l'a plutôt est associée au
reniement du programme à ce bricolage du
week-end fabriqués par emmanuel macron
qui fait que
d'un discours limpide sur l'euro alors
c'est peut-être pas applicable et
limpide
on est passé à quelque chose que plus
personne comprend y compris les
électeurs du front national et ça c'est
la faute de monsieur dupont aignan en
tout cas c'est ça lui attribue puisque
c'est lui qui probablement a voulu
édulcorer le programme donc on va lui
mettre sur le dos au final ça sera pas
un bon souvenir je pense pour les
militants frontistes sacre appelé
fichier les électeurs de nicolas dupont
aignan même si on a une grande partie
d'entre eux qui enfin 40% qui se
reportait sur marine le pen
il ya quand même une partie d'entre eux
qui a été aussi assez déconcertés par
cette alliance et qui nous ont dit par
exemple avoir désapprouvé l'attitude de
nicolas dupont aignan donc ça a pu aussi
heurter une partie de cet électorat qui
ne va pas se mobiliser en masse pour
marine le pen d'une part entre herman
busan qu'elle institue si c'était le
vôtre ou non mais j'avais vu qu'une
grande partie des électeurs de double
dip au dessus décidé de voter emmanuel
macron dans une forme d'incohérence bons
qu'ils étaient propres et qui n'est pas
condamnable en soi simplement de nicolas
dupont aignan a joué un rôle va compter
joué un rôle important dans cette
élection présidentielle est candidat
réussir à avoir ces signatures être
candidat pour jouer un rôle il a joué un
rôle important
il a pris des certainement des points à
françois fillon
peut-être même l'a dit l'empêché de se
qualifier au détriment de marine le pen
au second tour c'est difficile à évaluer
mais c'est une hypothèse est là avec
cette histoire de l'euro il joue à
nouveau un rôle où il est à nouveau un
rôle d'empêcheur alors certainement pas
pour marine le pen gagne la
présidentielle c'est pas ça qui va la
faire à lui faire perdre la
présidentielle mais mais où où ça ça
brise un petit peu son image même si
elle même avec le débat a ajouté à cette
confusion sur son image sur ce qu'elles
avaient construit patiemment sur la
crédibilité tout ce qu'on a dit un peu
plus tôt nicolas lebourg pour terminer
en cas de défaite de marine le pen
dimanche est ce qu'elle pourra encore
sauver sa tête s'il y aura beaucoup de
conséquences on imagine au sein du front
national avec toujours cette menace de
la rupture on se souvient notamment
entre les mégrétistes avec deux courants
qui s'opposent alors de deux choses
d'abord l'élection n'est jamais joué
tant que le peuple souverain ne s'est
pas exprimé à s'assécher dimanche soir
que je sois clair c'est le peuple
souverain qui tranche
mais maintenant non le parti n'explosera
pas il n'y a pas de risque de scission
marine le pen est une chef incontesté
dans un parti où le président a tous les
pouvoirs distribuer tous les postes et
peut vous enlever tous vos privilèges du
jour au lendemain ce qui calme beaucoup
de gens là si ce fut la rue plusieurs
reste un très bon et bien merci nicolas
lebourg merci à tous les l5 d'avoir
participé à cette émission c'est la fin
de cette édition d'ailleurs merci à vous
d'avoir suivi à 22h vous retrouver sonia
mabrouk et ses invités très bonne soirée
et à dimanche pour une soirée spéciale
sur les chaînes parlementaires à
l'occasion de ce second tour de la
présidentielle
au public
[Musique]